Katrina: 放冷冻室
Katrina: Put it in the freezer.
其他人：已经化成一坨了
Others: It's already melted into a lump.
Katrina: 没有他可能是变硬了
Katrina: No, it might have just hardened.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
其他人：呀到点了
Others: Oh, it's time.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我没说话呀
Katrina: I didn't say anything.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 还是等老板来吧
Katrina: Let's wait for the boss to come.
Katrina: 整的跟那个学术会议一样
Katrina: Feels like an academic conference.
Katrina: 还有甜点
Katrina: And there's even dessert.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: welcome our BIG boss JK杨
Shure: Welcome our BIG boss JK Yang!
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Jake:为什么第一个boss
Jake: Why the first boss?
Jake:BIG boss
Jake: BIG boss
Jake:哦哦第一个boss
Jake: Oh, the first boss
Jake:好嘞好嘞好
Jake: Alright, alright
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome, everyone
Jake:欢迎志愿者的朋友们是吧
Jake: Welcome, our friends and volunteers, right?
Jake:那个远道而来很不容易
Jake: It wasn't easy to come from so far
Jake:这个地方很偏
Jake: This place is quite remote
Jake:我们原来呃这个在整个北京的范围内
Jake: Originally, we, uh, in the whole Beijing area
Jake:选了一个
Jake: Chose a
Jake:最靠近北京市中心的一个别墅
Jake: Villa that's closest to the center of Beijing
Jake:就在这个地方
Jake: Right here
Jake:但是但是还是很欢迎大家可以过来吧
Jake: But still, we really appreciate everyone coming over
Jake:啊我们呃可能大家也都有有所听说
Jake: Ah, we, uh, maybe everyone has heard
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Alice:变形
Alice: Transformation
Jake:就是我们这个项目了
Jake: This is our project.
Jake:他就是一个叫Egle life的一个项目
Jake: It's a project called Egle Life.
Jake:他嗯
Jake: It, um...
Jake:你们也看到了
Jake: As you can see,
Jake:我们每人戴一个奇怪的眼镜
Jake: each of us is wearing strange glasses.
Jake:然后一圈都是摄像头对吧
Jake: And there are cameras all around, right?
Jake:然后这是为什么呢
Jake: So, why is that?
Jake:这是我们要采集一个第一视角的数据
Jake: We need to collect first-person perspective data.
Jake:和一个第三视角的数据
Jake: And third-person perspective data.
Jake:这边有8个摄像头
Jake: There are 8 cameras here.
Jake:这边有7个摄像头
Jake: 7 cameras here.
Jake:楼下有6
Jake: 6 downstairs.
Jake:这楼下有8个
Jake: And 8 downstairs.
Jake:然后每人有一个
Jake: And each person has one.
Jake:你这个电就没了
Jake: Your battery ran out.
Jake:如果大伙看到我们志愿者
Jake: If you see any volunteer
Jake:有人这个眼睛上面的灯不亮了
Jake: whose glasses light is off,
Jake:就要告诉他
Jake: let them know.
其他人：我就是给大家做一个示范
Other: I'm just giving everyone a demonstration.
其他人：这都是设
Other: This is all set...
其他人：这都是设计好的
Others: This is all planned.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:嗯我们收集这个第一视角视频呢
Jake: Uh, we collect these first-person view videos
Jake:就是为了去做分析
Jake: to do some analysis.
Jake:分析我们大概一周啊
Jake: We analyze roughly for a week,
Jake:这些人啊
Jake: what these people are doing.
Jake:都在干什么
Jake: Then, for today,
Jake:然后为今天啊形成一个一天的日记啊
Jake: we create a daily journal and plans for the next day.
Jake:然后第二天的一些plan呢
Jake: Basically, these tasks.
Jake:大概这些任务
Jake: But these aren't important.
Jake:当然这些都不重要
Jake: What’s important is,
Jake:我们重要的是
Jake: we welcome everyone to join our Earth Day
Jake:我们欢迎各位来参加我们今天earth day
Jake: weekend event today.
Jake:weekend的这个活动啊
Jake: Thank you, everyone.
Jake:谢谢大家
Jake: Thanks, guys.
其他人：好
Others: Good.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then,
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no,
Jake:我们先切出去
Jake: let's switch out first.
Jake:我们先切出去我们要
Jake: Let’s switch out first, we need to...
Jake:好这么难切
Jake: Wow, this is hard to switch.
Jake:我要切到另一个屏
Jake: I need to switch to another screen.
Jake:这个就是我在
Jake: This is what I...
Jake:这个是我们
Jake: This is our...
Jake:呃一个纪录小纪录片
Jake: uh, a little documentary.
Jake:好吧一个未完篇的纪录片
Jake: Well, an unfinished documentary.
Katrina: 我都不知道还有这玩意
Katrina: I didn’t even know about this.
Jake:我们在我们这个项目呢
Jake: In our project,
Jake:是4月13号
Jake: on April 13th,
Katrina: 是我靠
Katrina: Oh my god,
Katrina: 我真的
Katrina: I really...
Jake:我们见到的第一位志愿者
Jake: we met the first volunteer,
Jake:刘宇轩同学
Jake: Liu Yuxuan.
Jake:在北京几站
Jake: At Beijing West Station.
Jake:西站对
Jake: Yes, the West Station.
Jake:北京西站
Jake: At Beijing West Station.
Katrina: 我靠你知道当时我有多社死吗
Katrina: Oh my god, you know how socially awkward I was?
Jake:他拿到了这个眼镜
Jake: He got these glasses.
Jake:我们也用了我们的小包去欢迎他
Jake: We also used our little package to welcome him.
Jake:抵达北京
Jake: Arriving in Beijing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:对刘宇轩第一天很开心的样子
Jake: On Liu Yuxuan's first day, he looked really happy.
Jake:戴上眼镜之后就不太开心了
Jake: But after putting on glasses, he didn't look so happy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:看起来哈哈
Jake: It seemed like he was forcing a smile.
Jake:强装开心
Jake: Pretending to be happy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:然后我们第二位嘉宾露西亚还在楼下
Jake: And then our second guest, Lucia, is still downstairs.
Jake:是在北京首都机场
Jake: At Beijing Capital Airport.
Jake:我们两位同学
Jake: Our two students.
Jake:在绝味鸭脖前进行了会晤
Jake: Met in front of Juewei Duck Neck.
Jake:那是进行了一些简单的眼睛教导
Jake: They had some basic eye teaching.
Jake:比如说这个眼睛亮灯才能使用
Jake: For example, the eyes need to light up to be used.
Katrina: 这歌是现场生成的吗
Katrina: Was this song generated live?
Jake:大家可能意识到了这个背景音乐啊
Jake: Everyone might have noticed this background music.
Katrina: 是刚刚生成的AI
Katrina: It was just generated by AI.
其他人：恩AI做的
Others: Yeah, made by AI.
Katrina: 我就说怎么有EGOLIFE EGOLIFE
Katrina: I was wondering why it was saying EGOLIFE EGOLIFE.
Jake:可能也没有意识到这个背景音乐呢
Jake: Maybe you didn't notice the background music.
Jake:它是solo AI生存的这个title它
Jake: It was solo AI survival, the title is.
Jake:它的这个名字叫Eagle life
Jake: It's called Eagle life.
Jake:是我们的project name啊
Jake: It's our project name.
Jake:大家可以注意一下
Jake: You can pay attention.
Jake:这个一些歌词是用到了
Jake: Some of the lyrics are.
Jake:我们就是都
Jake: They are all.
Jake:都是我们内部的一些梗
Jake: All our internal jokes.
Jake:有些人可能知道
Jake: Some people might know.
Jake:对这个人
Jake: About this person.
Jake:秀儿哎
Jake: Xiuer, hey.
Jake:秀儿已经过去了
Jake: Xiuer has already passed.
Jake:因为这个秀儿这个镜头没有被捡到
Jake: Because Xiuer's footage wasn't picked.
Jake:原因是没时间
Jake: The reason was no time.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh dear.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:好欢迎大家来到我们的EQ二c
Jake: Alright, welcome everyone to our EQ2c.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:是啊我们刚刚呃应该是
Jake: Yeah, we just, uh, should have...
Jake:上课间我也没有时间剪
Jake: During class break, I didn't have time to edit.
Jake:所以不好意思他还没来
Jake: So sorry, he's not here yet.
Jake:他还在楼下
Jake: He's still downstairs.
Jake:对但是没关系
Jake: Yeah, but it's okay.
Jake:回头再剪
Jake: We'll edit it later.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我们来进入正题
Jake: Let's get to the main topic.
Jake:今天呢我们原计划哈哈哈
Jake: Today, we originally planned, hahaha...
Jake:如果一切都很顺利的话
Jake: If everything went smoothly,
Jake:是这么个时间线
Jake: This would be the timeline.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:但是自然而然的很不顺利
Jake: But naturally, things didn't go smoothly.
Jake:就是但是我们就往后顺延对吧
Jake: So we'll just push it back, right?
Jake:现改现在是几点
Jake: Now, what's the time?
Jake:我们来现改
Jake: Let's change it now.
Jake:哈哈哈四点零七
Jake: Hahaha, it's 4:07.
Jake:四月名7
Jake: April 7th
Katrina: 全员P人
Katrina: All members P people.
Jake:好四点零七
Jake: Okay, 4:07.
Alice:啊我也没看过
Alice: Ah, I haven't seen it either.
Jake:我们进行到了introduction的一半的部分
Jake: We're halfway through the introduction part.
Katrina: 你懂吗我真受不了哈哈
Katrina: You know, I really can't stand it, haha.
Jake:好吧哈哈哈现改这就是
Jake: Alright, hahaha, change it now, this is...
Shure: 其他不重要
Shure: The rest doesn't matter.
Shure: start time对的
Shure: The start time is correct.
Shure: 咱们就OK了
Shure: Then we're good.
Shure: 你看看我们精准的控制到4.07
Shure: Look, we precisely controlled it to 4:07.
Jake:好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
Shure: 来进行我们这个introduction部分
Shure: Let's proceed with our introduction part.
Jake:好再过
Jake: Alright, let's...
其他人：反方向过反方向的中国
Others: Moving in the opposite direction of China.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:再过20多小时之后
Jake: In over 20 hours,
Jake:我们就结束了今天的运打史
Jake: We will finish today's schedule.
其他人：再过3个小时啊
Others: In 3 more hours.
Jake:啊然后下面我们会进行一些啊
Jake: Ah, then we'll proceed with some...
Jake:因为我们这七天前
Jake: Because in the past seven days,
Jake:前六天我们让每个志愿者
Jake: For the first six days, we let each volunteer...
Jake:都装饰了自己的房间
Jake: Everyone decorated their own rooms.
Jake:装饰成了一个主题来和和这个EGO EARTH
Jake: They decorated them with a theme to match with EGO EARTH.
Katrina: 我还没弄完
Katrina: I haven't finished yet.
Katrina: 我我买了个那个蝴蝶风铃
Katrina: I bought a butterfly wind chime.
Jake:和这EARTH stay做一个呼应
Jake: To match with the EARTH stay.
Katrina: 但是他要用热熔敲
Katrina: But it needs to be hot-glued.
Jake:然后我们就很期待
Jake: We're really looking forward to it.
Katrina: 就一个个教
Katrina: Just need to teach me step by step.
Jake:各位志愿者的小屋装
Jake: All the volunteers' rooms are decorated.
Katrina: 哇我的海边
Katrina: Wow, my beach theme.
Jake:装饰成了什么样子
Jake: How they decorated them.
Katrina: 我的海报掉了
Katrina: My poster fell down.
Jake:对然后一会我们就会进行一个参观
Jake: Yes, and later we'll have a tour.
Jake:然后参观之后呢
Jake: And after the tour,
Katrina: 我本来墙上贴了一个小狗的海报
Katrina: I had a dog poster on the wall.
Jake:我们会有一个QA的环节
Jake: We'll have a Q&A session.
Jake:呃如果早来的观众呢
Jake: If you arrived early,
Jake:你们可能会经历一个
Jake: You might experience a
Jake:找找这个EOB的一个环节
Jake: Find the EOB activity.
Jake:就是可能在一楼啊二楼啊
Jake: Like on the first or second floor,
Jake:会有一些藏着小贴画啊
Jake: There will be some hidden stickers.
Jake:如果找到的话我们下面会有一个action
Jake: If you find them, we'll have an action.
Jake:action就是拍卖
Jake: The action is an auction.
Jake:我们会有一些小商品和这个
Jake: We'll have some small items and...
Katrina: 你带的什么
Katrina: What did you bring?
Katrina: 钥匙扣吗
Katrina: Keychains?
Jake:可能各位客人也会带来一些呃小物件
Jake: Maybe some guests will bring small items too.
Jake:然后我们进行一个拍卖
Jake: Then we'll have an auction.
Jake:就用我们发售的这个EGO calling已经
Jake: Using the EGO calling we issued,
Jake:上链了
Jake: It's already on the chain.
Jake:对这个十年大家保存好这个呃EGO calling
Jake: Keep the EGO calling for ten years.
Jake:可能过十年之后大家就财富自由
Jake: Maybe in ten years, you'll be financially free.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:呃按照原计划5点半
Jake: According to the original plan, 5:30.
Jake:但是现在不知道是什么时候
Jake: But now, who knows what time it is.
Jake:这个不重要哈哈哈
Jake: It's not important, hahaha.
Jake:就是我们就会进行啊
Jake: Then we'll start,
Jake:到了party time就是吃吃喝喝玩玩乐乐
Jake: When it's party time, we'll eat, drink, and have fun.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:呃会有一些音乐活动大家也知道
Jake: Uh, there will be some music events, as everyone knows.
Shure: 大家也知道
Shure: Everyone knows.
Jake:我们大家也看到这个阵仗特别的强势
Jake: We've all seen that this setup is particularly strong.
Jake:嗯那我们来进行这个就不管他了
Jake: Well, let's proceed with this and just ignore it.
Jake:这个一个Coin就是我们
Jake: This Coin is basically...
Jake:就是大家记好这个
Jake: Just remember this...
Jake:这个标就是如有雷同
Jake: If it looks similar, it's fake, don't buy it.
Jake:就是假的就不要买
Jake: It's fake, don't buy it.
Jake:嗯好这个我们可能先我们先进行
Jake: Well, let's proceed...
Jake:TRUO活动吗还是
Jake: With the TRUO event, or...
Katrina: 还是等一下
Katrina: Or wait a moment.
Katrina: 你们先进去
Katrina: You guys go ahead.
Katrina: 这个我要进去搜一下
Katrina: I need to go in and check something.
Jake:你要先进行啊
Jake: You need to proceed first?
Jake:你要先说一下那我们先进行QA的活动
Jake: You need to say something first, then we'll proceed with the QA event.
Jake:好一切都在我们军人的掌控之中
Jake: Alright, everything is under our control.
Katrina: 好哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Okay, hahaha.
Jake:一切都在计划之中
Jake: Everything is going according to plan.
Shure: 就我们我们这个项目只有一位
Shure: So, we only have one person for this project.
Shure: 只有一位是这人
Shure: Only one person.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哦欢迎你
Jake: Oh, welcome.
Jake:好啊早上好
Jake: Alright, good morning.
Katrina: 早上好
Katrina: Good morning.
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Katrina: 起床了
Katrina: Time to get up.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Katrina: 比哦厉害厉害
Katrina: Wow, impressive.
Shure: 好那没有其他的选项了
Shure: Alright, there are no other options.
Katrina: 没有其他的
Katrina: No other options.
Shure: 公布答案杨老板 90%
Shure: Announce the answer, Jake. 90%.
Jake:90
Jake: 90.
Shure: 我们其实世界呃
Shure: Actually, our world...
Shure: 就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: The largest freshwater resource on Earth...
Shure: 都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: Is locked in the Antarctic ice sheet.
Shure: 对所以是90%
Shure: So, it's 90%.
Shure: 然后这题也三个例子吧
Shure: And, this question also has three examples.
Alice:提问冰盖跟奶盖什么关系
Alice: Question, what's the relationship between ice sheets and milk foam?
WHTEDDM1:好问题好问题
WHTEDDM1: Good question, good question.
Jake:题好问题
Jake: Good question, good question.
Shure: 就是在我说说你听听
Shure: Let me just talk, and you listen.
Shure: 在想当初大约3,500万年前
Shure: Thinking back about 35 million years ago...
Lucia: 有50%的字是一样的
Lucia: 50% of the words are the same.
Shure: 继女娲补天的时候
Shure: During the time when Nuwa mended the sky...
Shure: 创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: She created a pair of twins.
Shure: 一个叫冰盖
Shure: One was called Ice Cap,
Shure: 一个叫奶盖
Shure: and the other was called Milk Cap.
Katrina: 什么东西
Katrina: What are you talking about?
Shure: 对大概就是这么回事您说
Shure: Yeah, that's basically the story. Your turn.
Lucia: 本来想坐那
Lucia: I wanted to sit there...
Lucia: 但是感觉坐那好像会挡住后面的嘉宾
Lucia: But it feels like sitting there would block the guests behind.
其他人：我印象里
Others: In my impression...
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey...
其他人：他的淡水是72%
Others: Its freshwater is 72%.
Lucia: 要不然还是坐这吧
Lucia: Maybe it's better to sit here.
其他人：但是他的冰盖是90%
Others: But its ice cap is 90%.
其他人：但你这个题的问题是
Others: But your question is...
其他人：他就储存多少淡水
Others: How much freshwater does it store?
其他人：不是冰盖有多少水
Others: Not how much water is in the ice cap.
其他人：我觉得你可以看一下
Others: I think you should check it out.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No...
Shure: 他是就是占占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: It's about how much of the global freshwater it accounts for.
其他人：但是你这个说是淡水90%应该就是水
Others: But you said 90% freshwater, it should be just water.
其他人：不是淡水
Others: Not freshwater.
其他人：我觉得你可以看一下
Others: I think you should check it out.
其他人：有没有人在搜一下
Others: Is anyone searching for it?
其他人：你看是不是
Others: Let's see, right?
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no...
Shure: 有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone challenged it.
Shure: 然后呢南极波盖
Shure: And then, the Antarctic ice cap...
Jake:直播直播搜索
Jake: Live search, live search.
其他人：波盖的面积超过这个14
Others: The area of the ice cap exceeds 14...
其他人：后面6个0平方公里
Others: followed by six zeros square kilometers.
其他人：厚度达到4公里以上
Others: The thickness is over 4 kilometers.
其他人：所含的冰量
Others: The amount of ice contained...
其他人：相当于地球上所吸干水质量的约70%
Others: is about 70% of the Earth's freshwater mass.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah...
Lucia: 70是吗
Lucia: 70%, right?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah...
Lucia: 我要退回去了
Lucia: I'm going back.
其他人：为什么出现了幻觉
Others: Why are we seeing hallucinations?
Alice:是水有70%
Alice: It's because 70% of the Earth is water.
Alice:陆地有30%
Alice: Land makes up 30%.
Alice:然后这个水的70%的水里面有90%的水
Alice: And 70% of that water is in the oceans.
Katrina: 天呐竟然头脑风暴开始
Katrina: Oh my god, brainstorming has started.
Alice:是才是啊对
Alice: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 好不符合我们这几片基调啊
Katrina: This doesn't fit our theme at all.
其他人：如果你把那个淡字去掉的话就是90%
Others: If you remove the word "fresh", it's 90%.
Lucia: 大家好认真
Lucia: Everyone is so serious.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈没想到哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, I didn't expect that, hahaha.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 是的那
Shure: Yes, that's it.
Alice:对因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Right, because not all water is fresh water.
Alice:转移一下资产
Alice: Move some assets.
Jake:转移资产
Jake: Move assets.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
其他人：但我不确定哪 三个是原来的
Others: But I'm not sure which three are the original ones.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: Then let's give another coin to...
Shure: 查出正确答案的同学
Shure: ...the student who finds the correct answer.
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 那么下一题
Shure: Now, the next question.
Shure: 地球的南极
Shure: The Earth's South Pole.
Shure: 他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: It makes my comeback awkward.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 从太阳到地球
Shure: From the Sun to the Earth,
Shure: 阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: how long does it take for sunlight to reach us?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This...
Shure: 其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: is something we used to calculate a lot in high school.
Shure: 哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Oh, two students have raised their hands already.
其他人：A呀
Others: It's A.
Shure: 8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes 19 seconds.
Shure: 哎我其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Actually, you both raised your hands at the same time.
Shure: 那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have any other answers?
其他人：我选D
Others: I'll choose D.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 0前
Shure: 0 before.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 你知道这个地意味着什么意思吗
Shure: Do you know what this place means?
Shure: 就是我们的表转了20圈
Shure: It means our clock has turned 20 times.
Shure: 才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: Only then will we see the sun.
Alice:确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there's a correct answer.
Shure: 确保一定有一个正确答案
Shure: Make sure there's a correct answer.
Alice:为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For our smooth progress.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah ah ah
Shure: 这这位同学纠正了我的
Shure: This classmate corrected my...
Shure: 我的错误
Shure: My mistake.
Shure: 是表转了40圈
Shure: It's 40 turns.
Shure: 是20圈啊
Shure: It's 20 turns.
Shure: 对对对我疏忽了
Shure: Yes, yes, I overlooked it.
Shure: 哎正确答案就谁
Shure: Hey, the correct answer is who?
Shure: 是吧对
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是8分19秒
Shure: It's 8 minutes and 19 seconds.
Shure: 大家还记得那个怎么算的吗
Shure: Do you all remember how to calculate it?
Katrina: 你现在推一遍
Katrina: You explain it now.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 是是就其实就是这么简单对
Shure: Yes, yes, it's actually this simple.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
其他人：哈哈是这样的
Others: Haha, that's right.
其他人：所以如果真的是二等天的话
Others: So if it really is a second-rate sky,
其他人：那那南极应该肯定不会占地球的
Others: then Antarctica definitely wouldn't occupy
其他人：占70 %
Others: 70% of the Earth.
Tasha: 起码太阳没了
Tasha: At least the sun is gone.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 地球还能看到太阳持续发光
Tasha: The Earth can still see the sun shining.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 但问题太阳是持续发光
Lucia: But the problem is the sun keeps shining.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 他们是串一下然后又熄灭
Tasha: It's not like it blinks and goes out.
Lucia: 他又不是串一下然后又熄灭哈哈
Lucia: It doesn't blink and go out, haha.
Shure: 你们你们2位
Shure: You two,
Shure: 每人两个
Shure: each have two.
其他人：所以会另一方面感谢
Others: So on the other hand, thank you.
其他人：是如果这个样子的话
Others: If that's the case
其他人：太阳坏掉了的话你还能再看
Others: If the sun breaks, you can still watch
Lucia: 再活20天哈哈
Lucia: Live another 20 days, haha
其他人：可能现在看到是8分钟之前的眼光
Others: Maybe what you're seeing now is from 8 minutes ago
Shure: 很乐观
Shure: Very optimistic
其他人：也就是我先看了8分钟之前
Others: So I saw it 8 minutes earlier
Lucia: 太阳冷却了
Lucia: The sun cooled down
Lucia: 我们还能再活20天
Lucia: We can still live for 20 more days
Katrina: 哈别把谢冰茹搞蒙了
Katrina: Haha, don't confuse Xie Bingru
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question
其他人：谁谁谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
Shure: 陨石
Shure: Meteorite
Shure: 为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why does it always hit the crater precisely?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 谁把这个问题加进去了
Lucia: Who added this question?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 这是一个开放性问题
Shure: It's an open-ended question
Shure: 根据你们的回答
Shure: Based on your answers
Shure: 我进行判断
Shure: I'll make a judgment
Shure: 给你们发币
Shure: And give you coins
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Okay, okay
Shure: 这个每人都来回答一下来
Shure: Everyone, answer this one
其他人：觉得这可以转化成一个前述范式的
Others: I think this can be turned into a precedent
其他人：问题就是它是一个因果的问题
Others: The question is about causality
其他人：就是有陨石坑
Others: There is a crater
Alice:这个
Alice: This
其他人：这是一个前置命题
Others: It's a prior proposition
其他人：然后它推出它可以找出后面那个问题
Others: Then it leads to the following question
其他人：那么如果前面的问题是一的话
Others: If the previous question is one
其他人：那后面的问题肯定是一个有陨石坑
Others: The next question is surely about a crater
其他人：所以说肯定有陨石坑
Others: So, there's definitely a crater
其他人：如果前面那个没有陨石坑的话
Others: If there wasn't a crater in front
其他人：他这个里面这个这个病题始终是真的
Others: This problem inside here is always real
Tasha: 他已经得满分了哈
Tasha: He already got a perfect score
其他人：所以说哈哈哈
Others: So, hahaha
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
其他人：虽然很想同意这个话
Others: Although I really want to agree with this
其他人：但是呢还
Others: But still
Katrina: 老婆饼为什么没有老婆啊
Katrina: Why is there no wife in wife cake?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
其他人：陨石坑为什么一定要有陨石
Others: Why does a crater need to have a meteorite
其他人：老婆饼没有老婆
Others: Wife cake doesn't have a wife
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 反抗辩手
Shure: Counter-debater
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
其他人：因为我觉得老婆饼和老婆没有明确的
Others: Because I think there's no clear connection
其他人：明确的一个谁造成谁的
Others: No clear cause between wife cake and wife
Tasha: 认可吧认可认可认可认可
Tasha: Recognize it, recognize, recognize, recognize
其他人：但是陨石坑是由陨石造成的
Others: But a crater is caused by a meteorite
其他人：你不能说是老婆饼是由老婆造成的
Others: You can't say wife cake is caused by a wife
Tasha: 我们俩至少跟他不在一条线上
Tasha: At least we're not on the same page as him
Katrina: 哦有一个这样的内在的原因在里面
Katrina: Oh, there's an inherent reason for that
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 那我们宣判反方一
Shure: Then we'll declare the opposition one
Shure: 正方一变赢了
Shure: The proposition won one round
Shure: 好你先思考然后
Shure: Okay, you think about it first and then
Lucia: 我觉得是因为陨石自带GPS系统
Lucia: I think it's because meteorites come with a GPS
Lucia: 他肯定没有精确定位到陨石哈哈哈
Lucia: It definitely didn't accurately locate the meteorite, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 他说这个也不无道理
Shure: What he said isn't unreasonable
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 你有你有想到什么反例来反驳他吗
Shure: Do you have any counterexamples to refute him?
Alice:这题选C
Alice: This question, choose C
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 没有选项
Lucia: There are no options
Shure: 选c选项的同学也是非常的有个性
Shure: Choosing C is quite an individualistic choice
其他人：皇帝的身体
Others: The emperor's body
Shure: 好吧好吧
Shure: Alright, alright.
其他人：我能看到什么这
Others: What can I see here?
Lucia: 哇你的形体
Lucia: Wow, your posture.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 那这个问题我决定二二二
Shure: For this question, I decide two, two, two.
Shure: 二二给大家每人发两个一钩币好吧
Shure: Two, two, let's give everyone two tokens each, alright?
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Shure: 吃止痛药打架算开挂吗
Shure: Is taking painkillers before a fight considered cheating?
Lucia: 这跟地球人都没关系了
Lucia: This has nothing to do with Earthlings.
Shure: 这跟地球人没关系吗
Alice:这跟地球是什么关系
Alice: What does this have to do with Earth?
其他人：文明人干的事儿怎么能叫开挂呢
Others: How can what civilized people do be considered cheating?
其他人：是弱智吧
Others: It's probably foolish.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
其他人：是弱智吧拿出来的
Others: It's probably foolish to take it out.
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经有同学发现了盲点哈
Lucia: Hahaha, someone has already spotted the blind spot, huh?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:是我们从弱智吧找的问题
Alice: We got the question from the "Fool's Bar".
其他人：弱智吧训的大模型
Others: A model trained by "Fool's Bar".
Tasha: come on come on
Tasha: Come on, come on.
其他人：明显哈哈哈
Others: Obviously, hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：上一个这种东西
Others: The previous one was like this.
其他人：：一看就是中文高质量语料不提供了
Others: You can tell it's high-quality Chinese data that is no longer provided.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
其他人：是吧
Others: Right?
Shure: 这种大家换一个问题吧
Shure: Let's switch to another question.
Jake:哈哈哈没有更多了
Jake: Hahaha, no more questions.
Jake:但是最后有一个问题
Jake: But there's one last question.
其他人：也不是说不可以
Others: It's not impossible.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈非常
Katrina: Hahahaha, very...
Shure: 他的答案非常的好
Shure: His answer is very good.
Lucia: 相似相融哈哈哈
Lucia: Similar, integrated, hahaha
Shure: 必须再奖励一个
Shure: We must give another reward.
Shure: 现在收获非常颇丰
Shure: We've reaped a lot now.
Shure: 再下一个吧
Shure: Let's move on to the next one.
Shure: 不孕不育会遗传吗
Shure: Can infertility be inherited?
Shure: 大家觉得
Shure: What do you guys think?
其他人：试管希望试管代孕的方法
Others: The hope of using IVF or surrogate methods.
其他人：不是不可以
Others: It's not impossible.
Alice:这是不是要被逼了哈哈
Alice: Are we being forced into this? Haha.
其他人：或者或者
Others: Or, or...
其他人：你是指的是什么的
Others: What do you mean exactly?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊植物的三倍体是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, you mean the triploid plants? Hahaha.
其他人：梦幻狂喜
Others: Dreamlike ecstasy.
Jake:还有一个问题
Jake: There's another question.
Jake:之前从0到第14题中间有一个
Jake: Previously, from question 0 to 14, there was actually...
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:其实只有13题
Jake: only 13 questions.
Tasha: 对刚刚
Tasha: Right, just now...
Shure: 对刚刚有一个旗号
Shure: Right, there was a flag just now.
Shure: 没有大家有发现吗
Shure: Did everyone notice that?
Shure: 这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: It was an easter egg question.
Shure: 这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: This is a 5-point question.
其他人：那个汉堡C
Others: That burger C.
Shure: 这是一个竖
Shure: This is a vertical...
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The repetition is to confuse you.
Shure: 所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So, it was missed, huh?
Shure: 那重复的不算
Shure: The repetition doesn't count.
Shure: 那个遗漏了哪
Shure: Which one was missed?
Shure: 哪个旗号
Shure: Which flag?
Shure: 大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did everyone notice?
Shure: 0-13
Shure: 0-13.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 啊 0-13对
Shure: Ah, 0-13, right.
Shure: 0-13他他说7
Shure: 0-13, he said 7.
Shure: 9
Shure: 9.
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Ahahahahahaha.
Shure: 这这这位同学呢
Shure: This, this, this student here...
其他人：不是90吗
Others: Isn't it 90?
其他人：要猜一个没有的数字啊
Others: You have to guess a number that hasn't been guessed.
其他人：对 99 哈哈哈
Others: Right, 99! Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 艾克喝醉了
Katrina: Ike is drunk.
Shure: 他猜过了7
Shure: He already guessed 7.
Shure: 他猜过了9
Shure: He already guessed 9.
Shure: 他猜过了12
Shure: He already guessed 12.
Shure: 对 0-13里面
Shure: Right, within 0-13.
其他人：哦0-13年
Others: Oh, 0-13 years.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 13就是上一集哈哈
Shure: 13 was in the last episode, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈看来会议
Jake: Hahaha, looks like the meeting.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:老是这种难题
Alice: Always these tough questions.
Alice:我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: Liu Ting from our family won't participate.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one.
其他人：十
Others: Ten.
Shure: 十难难道要要遗落了吗
Shure: Ten, is it going to be left out?
Shure: 这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let me narrow it down for everyone.
其他人：五
Others: Five.
Shure: 在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: This number is not a prime number.
Tasha: 帮我说个三
Tasha: Say three for me.
Alice:4
Alice: Four.
其他人：三是质数
Others: Three is a prime number.
Lucia: 3
Lucia: Three.
Lucia: 4
Lucia: Four.
Alice:4
Alice: Four.
其他人：8
Others: Eight.
Shure: 8你
Shure: Eight, you.
Tasha: 四
Tasha: Four.
Shure: 继续 12
Shure: Continue, 12.
Lucia: 7哈哈
Lucia: Seven, haha.
Shure: 7是质数
Shure: Seven is a prime number.
Alice:不是质数
Alice: Not a prime number.
Shure: 5也是质数
Shure: Five is also a prime number.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 为什么我能精准的命中这些东西
Tasha: Why can I hit these things so accurately?
Tasha: 你们在说什么
Tasha: What are you all talking about?
Tasha: 三五七十一
Tasha: Three, five, seven, eleven
其他人：没剩几个了
Others: Not many left
Tasha: 1
Alice:一人猜一个
Alice: Each person guess one
Alice:5是质数
Alice: 5 is a prime number
Katrina: 哈哈哈啊
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 7年没写过数学了哈
Lucia: Haven't done math in 7 years, huh?
Shure: 哈行
Shure: Haha, okay
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 他坚持是5
Shure: He insists it's 5
Shure: 那我们也没有办法
Shure: So we can't do anything
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 您您8
Shure: You you 8
其他人：不是知数还是市不是
Others: Not a prime number, is it?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 不是指数
Shure: Not a prime number
Shure: 猜一个猜一个猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one, guess one, guess one
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 给面给面给面
Shure: Give face, give face, give face
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 他给我面子
Shure: He gives me face
Shure: 我的室友们他给我面子
Shure: My roommates, he gives me face
Shure: 好吧好吧那
Shure: Alright, alright then
Jake:翻翻呗
Jake: Flip it
Shure: 我我记住了是6
Shure: I I remember, it's 6
Alice:没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed it
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right
Shure: 所以没人猜
Shure: So no one guessed
Alice:6啊
Alice: 6, huh
Jake:确实没人才
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed right
Katrina: 避免了通货膨胀
Katrina: Avoided inflation.
Shure: 所以所以我们这个大奖只能留掉
Shure: So, so we can only keep this big prize.
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
其他人：能均分吗
Others: Can we split it evenly?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 是几啊
Tasha: What number is it?
Jake:6
Jake: 6.
Alice:6
Alice: 6.
Tasha: 不是有人猜了 6
Tasha: Didn't someone guess 6?
Jake:确实一个人都没猜到
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed it.
Jake:99倒是有人猜
Jake: Someone guessed 99 though.
其他人：给我5个吧
Others: Give me 5.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 那
Shure: So...
Shure: 我们其实就应该到我们的action time了
Shure: We should actually get to our action time.
Shure: 就我们的拍卖时间
Shure: It's our auction time.
Shure: 那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: Let's first welcome our host.
Shure: 我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure: 先来拍一拍东西
Shure: Let's have them auction something first.
Shure: 来掌声有请第一位
Shure: A round of applause for the first one.
Alice:不是我还没拿
Alice: But I haven't taken mine yet.
Jake:我们先统计一下b
Jake: Let's count the coins first.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 大家手上都有多少币
Shure: How many coins does everyone have?
其他人：我太有钱了
Others: I'm so rich.
Katrina: 你有几个了
Katrina: How many do you have?
其他人：无敌了
Others: Invincible.
其他人：哈哈太多了
Others: Haha, too many.
这不把你整个屋都买了哈哈
Others: I could buy your whole room, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 问一下吧
Tasha: Let's ask.
其他人：显得我脸好大
Others: My face looks so big.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈会p一下
Katrina: Hahaha, you can photoshop it.
Tasha: 那还邀请
Tasha: Then let's invite...
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my puppy up too?
其他人：我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Others: Should I bring my puppy up too?
Tasha: 有没有可能是
Tasha: Could it be...
Katrina: 你们俩一人一只小狗吗
Katrina: You each have a puppy?
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish doesn't have any lights.
Katrina: 我没有灯珠
Katrina: I don't have any lights.
Lucia: 它现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a light now.
Katrina: 他现在不是灯
Katrina: It's not a light now.
Lucia: 它只是水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish.
Lucia: 哈哈哈行
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Katrina: 哈哈行
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 我去请狗了
Lucia: I'm going to get the dog.
Katrina: 刚进去叠了个被子哈
Katrina: I just went in to fold a blanket.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:这是一只娇俏的
Alice: This is a delicate one.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Tasha: 不是人家关你屁事
Tasha: It's none of your business.
Katrina: 这是我当时嗯
Katrina: This is what I...
Katrina: 我还新买了一个手链
Katrina: I also bought a new bracelet.
Katrina: 就是那天在那个抖音上买的
Katrina: I bought it on TikTok that day.
其他人：哈哈因为昨天说他带了一本书我说
Others: Haha, because he brought a book yesterday, I said...
Katrina: 他可以调的
Katrina: He can adjust it.
Katrina: 好像他可以掰开
Katrina: It seems he can open it.
其他人：嗯咱俩
Others: Hmm, both of us...
其他人：咱俩在北京的缘分比较多
Others: We have a lot of connections in Beijing.
其他人： 哈哈我也没想到这次又在北京
Others: Haha, I didn't expect to be in Beijing again this time.
Katrina: 我也没想到这次又在北京
Katrina: I didn't expect to be in Beijing again this time.
Katrina: 你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 特搞笑
Katrina: It's so funny.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Katrina: 我我我真快成土著了
Katrina: I'm really becoming a local.
Shure: 我们统计完自己手上都有多少币了吗
Shure: Have we counted how many coins we have?
Shure: 来来报个数
Shure: Come on, report your numbers.
Katrina: 啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure: 自己手上有多少币
Shure: How many coins do you have?
Katrina: 数一下啊
Katrina: Count them.
Alice:20
Alice: 20.
Shure: 那个谢外
Shure: Except for the external ones.
其他人：20
Others: 20.
Shure: 外面的场记
Shure: The external scene.
Shure: 谢斌竹来谢斌竹
Katrina: 20
Katrina: 20.
Shure: 哎记一下账本
Shure: Hey, record it in the ledger.
Shure: 现在大家手里的币子
Shure: Now, the coins everyone has
Shure: 对你记
Shure: Yeah, remember
Shure: 因为你到
Shure: Because when you
Shure: 到时候发钱包嘛
Shure: When it's time to distribute wallets
Katrina: 多少个 15
Katrina: How many? 15
Shure: 呃报一个姓名或者代号
Shure: Uh, report a name or a code name
Tasha: 啊突然
Tasha: Ah, suddenly
其他人：啥代号
Others: What code name?
Katrina: 小杜呗小杜小杜小杜
Katrina: Xiao Du, Xiao Du, Xiao Du
Shure: 小杜小杜有15个币子
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du has 15 coins
Katrina: 小杜哈哈
Katrina: Xiao Du, haha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 非要加儿哦
Katrina: Must add "er", oh
Katrina: 小杜
Katrina: Xiao Du
Shure: 杜安迪的杜哈哈哈
Shure: Du Andi's "Du", hahaha
Tasha: 15 他有15个币
Tasha: 15, he has 15 coins
Shure: 这位这位同学
Shure: This student
Shure: 11
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 11